hhs had
had about two and a half days to
figure out where where they needed to go
in order to
meet the needs of the executive order
and so
our our first
order of business is um
fis 21
362.
and um
this is the one that is
26.5
million dollars
to
transfer
between
different
categories and also to
accept
fema money
forty three five
so um
i
yeah okay uh senator morris you have a
question
i have a question for lba
okay
um mike yesterday when i contacted you
the um this 26 million was
what i was trying to understand
from a fiscal committee point of view
how did it get there
how was it handled with fiscal how was
it handled with governor and council can
you explain to everyone
how it was handled and how much was
handled in this process
sure uh just for the record mike kane
the legislative budget assistant so it's
kind of a brief uh recap of history um
you'll remember the 2020 the the state
was under a state of emergency um
due to covid
as a result
the governor had this emergency powers
where he could act
and direct the agencies to accept and
authorize them to spend funds
during without fiscal without executive
council
uh during that time specifically the
state of emergency so during that time
in multiple
uh instances
fema funds were made available to the
state and so fema there's technically no
limit on the amount of fema funds that
are available to a state
um it just really has to be fema
eligible expenditures and you get the
approval of the federal government
so during 20 uh into 21
multiple actions were taking place
initially to authorize the governor
authorizing hhs uh to expend fema funds
um and then to put it into
it was usually like two or three classes
would be put into but then the agency
was given the authority under the
emergency powers to transfer as
necessary so a majority of that was
going into class 20
knowing that the agencies could always
transfer during the state of emergency
to where it was needed
so multiple instances um
there would be amendments increases
decreases to the femur amount to the
state match amount or the 25 percent at
the time
uh for the state match which they would
receive from cares funds again outside
of fiscal outside of executive councils
outside of the budget process so not a
involved in
to that level of detail that you used to
so all those actions it's upwards of
between the state match and the fertile
match over 212 million dollars of fema
funds um
were available like an authorization to
the department to use
uh through those years you can see in
this item in 21 362
for fiscal year 22 88.3 million dollars
of that is still available um
if we were still operating under
the emergency orders and using that the
governor was using that same process you
would not see this item but once that
emergency order ended
things have changed what comes to fiscal
instead of an informational item of
we've accepted we've transferred
these funds fiscal in executive council
now being asked to approve any transfers
or acceptance this is the first transfer
out of class 20 uh action number one
into attic class 20 current expense
where most of it
was budgeted over the last year or so
into contracts for operational services
because yes it's eligible fema funds now
you have an idea of what you want to use
these funds for um and then this the
second part is the accept and expend of
an additional 43.5 which again last year
would have just gone through and the
governor would have written a letter to
hhs authorizing them to accept these
funds but now since that state of
emergency has ended they do come and ask
fiscal and gnc to approve the accept and
expand of those additional fema funds so
that's kind of the history how we got
here so you wouldn't remember fiscal or
the finance committee's budgeting x
amount in class 20 or class 103 because
that all happened
did you have a follow-up yeah and the
follow-up is last year's money required
a match
this year the money we're talking about
here is 100
federal 100 instead of the 25
uh state match that you're used to
hearing about in fema for mostly the
safety items the federal government
during the state of emergency through
march i believe in the department can
clarify or verify that uh will support
seeing none
could i have a motion
to
approve fis 21
362.
thank you do i have a
second buy
approved by uh
motion was made by representative
leishman seconded by representative
edwards
uh this is a
motion to approve
362.
representative edwards yes
clerk votes yes
representative earth yes
representative leishman yes
senator daniels yes
senator morse yes
uh senator soucy yes
senator prentice yes
representative umberger yes
and i'm sure the vote is nine
nine yes one no okay
motion passes with a vote of nine in
favor and one opposed uh madam chair
yes
may i make a question about the bill we
just passed i it didn't wasn't germaine
to the vote itself but i do want to put
something on the record okay certainly
okay so um
so i realize the
uh
hurried nature the emergent nature of
getting this funding i i just want to
point out that
the governor
on facebook already advertised that
these uh
booster blitz was going to take place
and so i think there was a little cart
before the horse there that we can
excuse because of the emergent nature of
this but
but normally uh
advertising that the money is or the
program's going to be there because the
expectation of the money being there
that should not come before the actual
vote as a rule i think so
that's that's my comment thank you okay
thank you very much
okay
yes
sorry rep
senator mars
yeah this kind of went a lot faster than
i thought it was going to go but um
on this particular item that we just
passed um
the commissioner i'm just going to make
a suggestion in the future because
none of us knew about this kind of money
and and that's kind of strange for this
group
you know
so we have all this federal money
sitting in accounts um whether it's
class 20 or not class 20. um we never
talked about any of that in the budget
phase and the um
i just think it might be beneficial
to understand
how much money you know we can we can
look at this 88 and you're transferring
26 out of it but are there is there more
dollars in hhs in other accounts that
are federal funds that are sitting there
waiting for decisions to be made that
emergency like decisions i get that but
is that
so there are
several accounting units within hhs that
are related to covid yes and
um none of them were included in the
budget process if all of them have
either went through the state of
emergency into our budget or have come
before fiscal we we did actually bring a
fema item through fiscal i believe two
meetings ago and transferred money out
of class 20 um into class 103 um for
i'm trying to remember what that was for
exactly
i don't remember but um there are
several accounting units mostly in
public health uh that are that are like
this we just closed out
the go for cares act accounting unit
that um the spending on that just ended
so that um doesn't exist as of today but
did exist for the first uh six months or
so of the fiscal year
but there are several grants in public
health
follow up follow
karen the
you just brought up gopher and cares act
and some of us are working with this
billion dollars
and it's
difficult at best to get enough meetings
to talk about everything that's in there
but there is a chart that says here's
the original 900 and something this is
what's been spent
today
is that something that you're tracking
on your end or is it being tracked in
somewhere else
so
uh it depends on the grants and i would
say that hhs is always tracking
internally everything that we're
spending
the cares act funding we tracked
internally and we actually tracked the
cares act funding for the whole state
for a period of time until gopher had
enough staff to to do it themselves so
we were running the reports for the
entire state for a while
um
i can tell you in this fema account the
52 million or yeah yeah i'm looking at
the right one the 52 million that was in
class 103 in the current modified budget
on on number one that is already
encumbered into contracts or planned for
contracts um already which is why we
needed to transfer funds into there
so we do track that we actually
because of the emergent nature of what
we've been doing for the past two years
typically we just track encumbrances and
say you know we know we have these
things encumbered and we sort of know
what's coming up but because this
happens so quickly we have a lot of
spreadsheets that are tracking what's
coming up um because there's so many
things at once
yes senator mars
and trust me these questions would have
been asked before we voted um so i'm
just trying to go through it um
i think what you just brought up karen
um is exactly what this committee
would like to be involved with they they
would like to see
not like they feel it's their obligation
and this is no secret that i went to the
governor about it
you know if money's coming into new
hampshire where's it going
you have some pretty specific numbers in
here
on the next item
so i've got to believe you know what
you're doing
with these allocations
and we may be a pest
but i think if there's a way to
keep us updated i think that's what
we're asking
and i think one of the difficulties and
i i've been trying to figure out a
solution to this too is that
i can only share so much with this
committee because i have to take a
contract through the gnc process and
that process is confidential and can
affect contract negotiations so on the
next item when we start talking about it
i can give you some high level
information on how we came up with the
numbers but if i go into detail i risk
the negotiations we have going on with
potential contractors and potentially
pay a higher rate than we need to
because we put a number out there that's
higher than what they're willing to let
us pay them so we have to be
careful how we share the information and
anything we share with you is public so
there's no like oh we're sharing this
confidentially so i you know the i think
the best we can do is share the more
specific information afterwards which i
know doesn't help the vote which is hard
but i i don't want to put at risk our
contract negotiations
follow
and i'm sure others are going to have
questions but
what i what i see that you should be
prepared for though
is
at some point
there's going to be an audit by the
legislature of all these federal funds
that come in
um
during covet someone's going to ask the
question and it's bipartisan right i
mean you saw senator d'alessandro had
the same questions that i was headed
towards on on an item and
i
i think
it's not just the executive branch that
wants to see that
i'm just
no that's completely understandable i
will tell you that
kpmg did a single audit for fiscal year
20 already they've
completed that and
um they audited all of our coveted funds
because they all hit the threshold of
being um
being funds that have to be audited so
they are uh currently audited already by
the federal government right now
and if i can just add um
our our public health grants that we get
from the cdc
there's a lot of requirements around
auditing those and they're very specific
on what we can use them for so when you
see us accepting or requesting to accept
and expend a cdc grant
those funds we have to submit a plan of
action to them and anytime we change
that plan of action we have to modify it
and resubmit it to the cdc so those
funds are very
clearly tracked by the cdc in the
department and what i can see is during
the state of emergency we did accept
some multi-year cdc grants and we're
using some of those funds still today
but we we do have the tracking and we do
submit to cdc anytime we change what our
okay
i'm sorry if i
went too fast i apologize so
let us turn now to fis 21 um
which is
to accept and expend federal funds from
arpa in the amount of
20.4 million
and to authorize
these and further authorize these funds
to the accounts below
and it will be used to respond to
the
and
so
let me let me start out by asking are
there any questions
from people on the fiscal committee
uh yes go ahead uh madam chair i have
four questions uh do you want me to just
go one at a time or rotate or just go
one at a time okay uh i
i think three of them make sense
in combination but i'll i'll do that do
whatever you need
thank you
so um so good seeing you again
um i i'm looking forward to voting in
favor of uh this request uh but i i just
do have some standard questions that i'd
like to ask and find out what you what
you've thought about and that is um
i
i understand our your objective is to
make our
bed capacity more flexible so that we
have more options on how to address our
future needs that we aren't really able
to anticipate fully now
but
how
as you've planned for this have you
anticipated a goal for a benefit how
would you describe
what success looks like at the end of
this effort
sure thank you
so right now our hospitals are running
at 91 capacity and 91 percent makes it
sound like there's still nine percent
there but that nine percent could be in
pediatrics maternity
any of those what we do know is our
hospitals are transferring patients as
far away as connecticut and albany new
york um to get the the right level of
care that they need and we're not just
talking about covet patients we're
talking about patients with heart
attacks and strokes and things like that
when talking to the hospitals which we
have a daily call with the hospitals now
we used to have it twice a week it has
escalated to daily
you know they've listed things that
would assist in moving people out of the
hospital that do not need to be in the
hospital
one of the first groups are is elders
that are looking for nursing home or
assisted living level of care they are
unable to return home
but nursing homes and assisted livings
due to this their staffing issues due to
covid have shut down units have
decreased capacity
some of those people waiting in the
hospital
are new medicaid recipients which there
is a very lengthy process to
to approve medicaid when we were in the
state of emergency we were able to
bypass that process
we cannot do that right now so
what what we're doing with some of these
funds is guaranteeing to the facility
that if they take a medicaid pending uh
client that we will guarantee payment if
medicaid in the future is is not
approved so our overall goal
we've accounted for about 75 nursing
facility beds for over the next 120 days
and 30 assisted living beds now the
flexibility i need is that if for some
reason
50 assisted living beds come open
through this process and only 30 nursing
home beds i need to be able to move that
money around and use what we have to
empty out the back door of the hospital
ambulatory surgical centers which is
also in this item we're planning for
about 75 beds of hospitals being able to
internally surge into ambulatory
surgical centers and
the department
designating those areas as acute care
beds versus ambulatory surgical beds
rehab centers which have some capacity
right now to take some of the nursing
home residents that are waiting for
placement and we can't find beds for
we've accounted for we've allotted to 30
beds in in rehab centers and then eight
strike teams now we want to what we're
trying to do and there are several
facilities that have reached out several
county facilities in a couple of private
facilities that have said if you can get
us the staffing we can open up a 25 bed
unit in our nursing home and take those
hospitalized patients
so we're we're working with national
agencies that are able to bring people
in from out of state to help open up
those units the the strike teams are
fall into that we're we're hoping for
eight so measuring success is getting
capacity down below 80 percent which is
where it was before this surge in our
hospitals
making sure that the people that need
icu comprehensive icu level of care are
in an actual icu unit we have several
hospitals operating right now on a
team-based model of care
which is what you do
as a contingency plan when you have too
many patients and not enough staff
we'd like to end that and go back to our
normal standards of care
follow-up certainly
okay so this this is a follow-up to that
specific question and i i just want to
understand the apples to oranges numbers
because you um you mentioned an uh 91
uh uh at capacity now and then you've
mentioned 75 beds and 30 beds for you
know 105 beds
so then you mentioned uh that would get
us down our goal would be to an 80
capacity so so are you effectively
saying that those 105 beds represent 11
percentage points
so that's that's
that is not one moment in time so
it's over the next 120 days and even
maybe beyond that um so i may be able to
move 40 people out of the hospital today
60 days from now i may have an another
40 people in the hospital in those same
beds
so it's it's ongoing preservation of the
capacity within the hospital it's not
just one point in time
okay so what does that 105 represent in
terms of percentage points of your
capacity
sorry it's a math question yes and the
i i i just need the numbers so i can
understand relatively what we're doing
so
i don't want to misquote the number but
i think it's around four that would be
around four percent four percentage
points based on what i'm remembering for
a number so i'd want to verify that but
that's
all right if it's significantly
different i just appreciate knowing
just to add to that understanding that
in the last six months one nursing home
resident taking up a bed in a hospital
right
is equivalent to
you know maybe even 20 acute care
patients that only have three-day
hospital stays so by moving one
long-term care resident out you are able
to service dozens of acute care patients
thank you you're obviously dealing with
a complex and changing situation so i
appreciate what you all are doing uh my
my other question is uh similar to what
i asked you in the last meeting and that
is um i'm just curious
to the extent
that you know
that uh the hospital system is hurting
itself on a capacity level
by terminating
um
health care providers that do not want
to
voluntarily take the injection
so the cms
mandate was there's an injunction on the
cms mandate that came out last week
there are some there are some hospital
systems that have already chosen to go
through with the mandate um the hospital
association is going to track the number
of people that leave specifically
around the mandate but
my my understanding just from general
conversation is a very very tiny pool of
people
okay i i would just like some visibility
into that number if you are able to get
somebody to develop it i'd appreciate it
okay all right thank you madam chair
uh yes representative leishman
uh thanks man of chair
and thanks for responding to all my
written questions earlier
so under the strike teams for long-term
care staffing
you have
rates are estimated to be between two
and three hundred dollars could you
explain that is that
for the
overall
individuals as a group or is that per
person
so i wanted to clarify because i did
have a conversation with representative
erf this morning and i think i may have
miscommunicated so uh that rate is what
would be paid to the agency per person
per hour
so as a follow-up madam chair yes so the
individual wouldn't be getting that it
would be the contracting agency and they
would determine whether that person got
ten dollars or fifty dollars an hour i
mean it's so i mean as part of the
negotiations we have a sense of what
rate they're paying the individuals
typically but i
i
somebody that's being paid ten dollars
an hour is not who we're hiring in this
type of situation you know no no you
know rn is going to get paid 10 an hour
so i think that it it probably varies
per company just like any contracted
employee but it's not
this rate is a range for the contractor
and one further question yes please go
ahead thanks
so your department is taking on an
increasing role again and again and
again and
how is the staff handling this are
things being
put off that should be done in other
areas to handle this pandemic or
how are you
handling this staff and overseeing this
additional responsibility
i don't have a lot of perspective since
the entire time i've been commissioner
we've been in a covid pandemic so um
this has been kind of the volume of work
since i came on board as commissioner
we are operating all of our other
programs in the department at full
capacity
the staff within the department is
stretch thin and burning out
as you would expect and as every other
health care worker
in our state in every hospital in every
nursing home they're feeling the same
uh senator guido you have a question
uh turn your mind thank you madam chair
um
so that two to three hundred dollars
would that be a number that is inclusive
of all
the expenses personnel operating
benefits all that for those facilities
or there are other outside that 200 300
uh expenses no that that's the hourly
rate paid to the contractor
no other compensation
i don't believe so not that i know thank
you
yes senator susie thank you madam chair
uh just please uh turn on your mic and
it's not
i think it's on now
my question was relative to the
ambulatory surgery centers and the
ability to transfer into those my
understanding is the transfer would be
discretionary
um and i i just and i i'm very sensitive
to what karen said earlier about the
drilling down and getting into a
granular explanation but i just wondered
where the 9 million came from if you
could just give me some top line as to
how you establish that number given
the limited services that the surgery
centers are able to provide and given
also the limited stay
would it be an increased stay or
increase service that
i will answer part of that senator and
then i'll look here and talk about the
number part of it
the goal here is that there is a state
statute that allows the commissioner to
designate
um
other areas within the hospital as acute
care centers so the goal would be to
have a hospital that has an ambulatory
surgical center either attached or
detached to then designate that area as
an acute care center not as an
ambulatory surgical center so it would
function the same way as a normal
hospital bed without the hours without
the license limits on it
so i will speak to all of the rates so i
worked with henry libman the director of
medicaid to determine the average rates
in all of these types of facilities to
come up with the rate so the rate for
the ambulatory surgical centers is
actually based on a hospital rate um not
the ambulatory surgery okay that makes
sense as to why it's yes why it's higher
yes thank you you're welcome okay
are there any further questions
oh yes i'm sorry
thank you and good morning
um
to my understanding that you know when
we talk about nursing nursing facilities
ambulatory
rehabilitation or any of those that you
list there that
it's not mandated that they make room
that is correct
okay so my my follow-up question is then
when you when you designate
so many beds for a particular facility
how do you know that if you haven't done
if you haven't negotiated a contract
with them yet i have several facilities
such as nursing facilities that have
reached out and told me what their
capacity is if we can
provide them some of the the strike team
uh personnel see all of these items are
interrelated and depend on each other so
if i can provide them a strike team they
they
they said they can open up 25 beds
we then move medicaid pending people
that are waiting in the hospital into
those 25 beds and i guarantee payment
under with this funding so that they can
move into the hospital it had two county
facilities at least two county
facilities and three private facilities
already offer up units on their in their
buildings
okay thank you
are there any further questions
uh representative earth
thank you madam chair
what analysis has been done regarding
the
the expectation of the trend for the
rise and fall
that would definitely be a question for
our state epidemiologist around delta
because we have obviously have the
complicating factor now of the
omnichrome uh variant too
but i can certainly have uh dr chan
get back to you on what the what the
analysis is for the upward trend or the
downward trend of delta
okay
if if you would send that to the lba so
that we can all share that not just to
senator guida
thank you madam chair just a moment if i
may for some commentary
okay brief
um i voted against the first item
because
it is a is geared towards prevention
and understanding that this is a virus
that was deliberately given gain of
function another term is called
weaponized we're watching variants
continue to emerge
and we continue to chase
this ephemeral goal of stopping the
spread of the virus
so that was the reason for my vote
against first i will support this
measure because this is a treatment
measure we are enabling treatment of
people who have the virus
not chasing the ephemeral ghost of
trying to stop something
that continues to mutate at an alarming
rate and to spread all over the globe
thank you mr madam chair thank you
uh
representative edwards uh thank you
um
maybe you already answered this but for
the strike teams that you're that you're
augmenting
um
do you know if those strike team members
are going to be required to have
been vaccinated
i don't know that
okay
again it's not going to affect my vote
it's just an issue that's important to
me so if we could get an answer
the the overall goal with the strike
teams is we will be
there's not a lot of companies that can
give me eight strike teams we will
likely contract with four five six
different companies to each provide one
or two strike teams
and we can certainly ask that question
if as a private entity they've chosen to
implement a mandate or not my
my thought is that because the some of
the facilities that they're sending
their staff into have mandates that
they've probably either
only using people that have been
saying none uh could i have a motion to
approve
fis-21360
senator guida seconded by senator susie
this roll call for
clerk votes yes
representative erf yes
senator daniels yes
senator morris yes
senator geida yes
senator soucy
senator prentice yes
representative umberger yes
madam chair of the void is
10 yes
uh fis 21 363
passes on a vote of 10 to zero
uh thank you very much for uh coming
before us and
we look forward to great things out of
this
so um just for everyone's
information
our next fiscal committee committee
meeting is scheduled for
december 17th
at 10 o'clock
so if there's no further business